if uh you could go back and with all the  wisdom that you've gained over the years  if you could go back and tell  ten-year-old bob some advice give them  some advice based on everything that  you've learned what advice would you  give them  set a  i always have a goal  i have in my pocket a goal card  i've been carrying a gold card in my  pocket for years  since 1961.  when you decide on a goal you paint the  picture in words  when you do that you impregnate the  picture into a group of cells in your  brain  every time i touch that goal card it  triggers the picture in my mind  and as long as that picture is there i  keep moving the direction of it  and that is really the secret i think  to living a good life you got to have a  reason for it when you wake up in the  morning you have to have a good reason  for waking up and going to bed going to  work